[Music]
you
look who has the back she's right who
has their leg strength she does right
you're gonna have your Center okay so I
can't watch this I don't know why we
think that magically just look at it can
you see logically physiologically
tactically doesn't it's not good you're
not supposed to be here okay or she's
not supposed to be dead I do want to
know them okay so let's just start a a
simple drill the first movement was here
you see that difference what monster
that's already disturbing news Albany
are trying to do not figure eight with
the center whoa
[Music]
my birthday and he's never upright and
we're never on the same diet II even
though we will pass each other he's on
one part of the spiral behind me not on
the same part of the spiral just to the
back that's what you were doing okay so
you're gonna add a hike and
you
[Music]
Oh down did I break the rules I still
have my Fulbright even if you have to
talk you I have taught you to do you see
so you're not gonna you're not gonna
overpower my lights so I can't have my
kid doing a circle on the same old wood
that I'm doing circle that was the last
point and they can't be walking around
in perfect balance
okay
so yes I want them never to stop
so his movement okay but he has to be in
a compromised posture okay so I don't
know you will have to do different
things but you can't have them be
walking around like this you see that he
should already be falling like all our
techniques before the throat I am a TV
volume person so a lot of times you go
like this right and then you're going to
go no you're not compromise compromise
you see the last part Amy
[Music]
he should be off balance the entire time
almost about together okay don't take
them all the way off just it up and then
you're a mess all right let's go right
you
okay this sometimes when you're doing
the technique it's true I have to be in
the bathroom yeah but you cheap i10 is
actually an oriented here all right
here's the contention not not him okay
so when you go onto nerve
you don't go under the armpit you go
under the wrist
okay so I'll just show you simple so
yeah Here I am like this okay and look
at my shoulders I'm going under the
armpit live my shoulder here versus here
you see that so I would have less
strength lifting something up without
that self alignment versus it's
underneath me okay so when I when I'm
doing the tight end the hoochie cotton
it's here tonight go back it's not here
you see that he's going to be strong and
you're opening yourself up to all this
other stuff
but when you're out here out on their
wrist and the reason I'm mentioning that
is the second mistake that gives back
balance so what are you going you're
going here on them
is over his way okay
get to the buck you can be in the back
here I'm in the back okay because you
wanted to get Bonnie going off balance
so be careful that under your duty tank
time you're not here just keep it back
to him most you can't just let you but
that's trap
you
general reminders okay tactical concepts
they have to be always in a compromised
posture at door which always have been
answer balance is compromised and they
must keep moving and I can't give them
back
I can't uncheck that do you understand
that concept
Oh once you check something you it's
over here right once I check here I'm
not gonna go like that so if I if I blew
my chicken leg here I'm not gonna pick
him up so some of the same thing we're
here this is where I had you guys do
this one right he's check maybe you guys
love it
he's lunch at plank see that he's
checked people check okay hey you're
doing this bar no go like this you see
giving him that thing he throw be
geometry is I got the tilt and the hip
goes out you're not looking for this
kind of vision so you have to put
yourself in that position
we can't be in a position where you're
expecting that accelerated him and then
he got the forward room that's not what
we're doing we're setting up that
geometry
[Music]
you